There are all kinds of other cool stuff you can do with the data.
This is a cleaned up data set where I took these extreme values out manually.
And then I kind of want to scatterplot off today's weight versus last year's weight.
And when I do this, I get an interesting graph.
It is approximately linear, but there are some very funny outliers.
There's a point over here. Obviously someone thought I went from 0 to 200 within a year.
And there are also points over here that indicate massive weight loss
or massive weight gain within the span of a year.
And I have no clue why people believe I massively lost or gained weight.
But as a statistician, looking at the data is really informative.
It tells you that even in the spectrum of good guesses, there are some that are suspicious
or people likely didn't take the question very seriously.
As a statistician, your skill will be to look at these data points more deeply
and possibly remove them based on what you see in this scatterplot over here.
That goes way beyond the idea of quartiles but in the estimation of the mean
those phenomena have a massive impact as to what your final outcome looks like.
Thank you everybody for supplying the data that led to this programming unit.